hark a beard and mariachi music comes to
steal comments and resell them in comic
voices it's feedback EULA Here I am
hello and welcome to feed bakula the
show that takes what you've been saying
chews it up then vomited all over the
carpet like a really SH Doge coming up
this week thief it's out now but will it
steal your heart or just run off with
your money unfortunately reckons kevin
van audits the latter kevin gave
squeenix is stealth franchise revival
six out of ten picking bones with the
shoddy AI a choppy city riddled with
loading screens and a nap story initial
reactions ranged from disappointed too
bizarrely enough delighted loll as much
as this was being hype called it console
eyes dumb down garbage too bad thief
could not steal my heart wow just wow
screw you iris Montreal I'd still wait
to see what actual players have to say
about this it could just be that the top
review sites weren't paid off to give
this a good score iono tinfoil company
and i would like to thank you for
keeping us in business what a cluster
why could the devs a Jamaica good what a
disappointment I was really looking
forward to this game X Open bracket
thank God I waited for gs's review
before buying it the potential this game
had what a shame what a shame indeed you
guys really are going to base your
decision on a review from gamespot LMFAO
screw that I'm gonna buy this game and
I'm gonna love it good please do we're
not out to ruin your fun if we were we'd
do something like this if you reckon you
can see past the AI glitches with thief
and still have a good time go for it
some of the most entertaining games
around our broken as hell it's just only
fair to warn you about the bits that are
a bit well crap
so anyway alongside the usual
conversation of whether kevin was right
wrong or simply paid off there were a
lot of people saddened by the fact thief
hadn't managed to relive the glory days
of its stealth legacy which is
understandable really I doubt we'll ever
have a true stealth game ever again why
invest in a new IP when you can more
easily ruin an established IP they could
have named it bandit or Robin Hood Julia
instead I wasn't quite satisfied with
the stealth game player disordered ad
doorman absolution was a playable
nightmare so I was hoping for this to
give me what I want but I guess I've
just go to replay mark of the ninja
again hardly surprising this game had
Shh written all over it for a long time
another great PC franchise fall to the
wretched dumped down console ization
curse leave our classics be console
peasants ten years fans waited for a new
fief and they give us this the series
that created the stealth genre has been
reduced to a husband over genres finish
well I wouldn't say it's finished but it
certainly seems to have lost its way a
bit it's a shame thief missed the mark
but hey at least not everyone was
disappointed there were a few people
sticking up for it thief is good
gameplay is great dudes organelle thief
game with open-world guys come on game
is full burst of stealth doesn't shame
it is someone actually played this game
I don't believe reviews of GS anymore so
criminally bad reviews so criminally bad
english more like are you happy now Gabe
dollar pot now you've click baited
everyone it's a more traffic hit on your
site by giving a great Triple A game a
poor scores don't let this review change
your mind say ously I believe that when
we actually play it it will be much
better yeah the code will magically
transform into something different by
the glorious power of wishful thinking
look I haven't played thief chances are
you haven't either and chances are most
of us probably aren't
going to play it because it's got
commercial flop written all over it but
while we're here we may as well do this
merry little dance so here goes see I
totally understand why you're frustrated
people have wanted a proper thief game
for a long time and it looks like no
matter how hard they may have tried
Square Enix hasn't managed to revive the
franchise in the way we all hoped they
haven't brought the game back to life
Kevin hasn't brought it back to life
with his review and you haven't brought
it back to life with wishful thinking
even though we've all had a go I'm not
saying anyone is wrong for having hoped
thief might be a proper stealth game but
I am saying nobody should be surprised
it isn't with the exception of games
like dishonored which let's face it come
around once in a blue moon triple-a
isn't really the place to go looking for
a true stealth experience anymore sorry
about that if you do fancy a true
stealth experience though why not try
sneaking out of work early it's super
fun
you